before we go we're going to leave you
with some good vibes on this friday the
13th courtesy of post malone yes so just
last week it was revealed that post
malone and his girlfriend are expecting
their first child together with the
rapper confirming the news to tmz and
ahead of his musical appearance on
global saturday night live alongside
host selena gomez this weekend posts
stopped by the tonight show starring
jimmy fallon on thursday to share what
he's most looking forward to when it
comes to fatherhood take care everyone
bye-bye it's crunchy it is good first of
all congratulations i heard that you're
going to be a dad that's very true
thank you thank you so happy for you are
you are you preparing are you reading
the books are you uh
practicing diapers swaddling the most
important thing and you know people ask
me like oh what do you want to be as a
dad or like what do you i just i just
kindness is is the most important thing
for me so i guess that's what that's the
most important thing that's exactly
right you don't need to read very much
yeah and you also have mom to help you
out very much